so we're still still in the process of
learning about the police shooting
that left dante wright dead in brooklyn
minnesota that not brooklyn new york
brooklyn minnesota
and yesterday police had a press
conference about it
one of the strangest police press
conferences i've ever seen
in the middle of it the brooklyn police
chief tim gannon
just walked out he later returned there
were questions as to
why did he leave and the answers were
very strange
what we know is that police shot and
killed a black man
on sunday during a stop for a traffic
violation there have been protests there
has been unrest
i've looked at the video of the shooting
which we will not be playing uh
here uh but you can find it online we
know that the officer
uh announces that she will be tasing
but then she pulls out her gun and
shoots the individual apparently
and this is the case that you will see
made during this press
conference mistaking her gun
for her taser which uh is
immediately raising questions about how
could that be called an
accident if you are a police officer
it's your sort of main thing to know
do i have a taser in my hand or do i
have a gun are these my hand
handcuffs or is this a soda but we're
going to get to that
the man killed by police was identified
by relatives and by minnesota
governor tim waltz as dante wright 20
years of age
nbc reports that the state mobilized the
national guard when crowds
gathered in front of the brooklyn center
police department on sunday evening a
curfew was ordered it's been chaotic
let's get
into the clips one of the strangest
video police press conferences that i've
ever seen
here's the first part where chief tim
gannon says listen the officer announced
a taser but drew her handgun
that sort of seems like the officer
meant to tase dante wright
not shoot dante wright as you can hear
the officer while struggling with mr
wright shouts taser taser
several times that is part of the
officer's training prior to deploying a
taser
which is a less lethal device that is
done to make her partners aware
as well as a subject that a taser
deployment will be imminent
during this encounter however the
officer drew their handgun
instead of their taser for informational
purposes
we train with our handguns on our
dominant side
and our taser on our weak side so if
you're right-handed you carry your
firearm on your right side
and you carry your taser on the left
this is done purposefully and is trained
as i watch the video and listen to the
officer's commands it is my belief that
the officer
had the intention to deploy their taser
but instead shot mr right
with a single bullet
this appears to me from what i viewed
and the officer's reaction in distress
immediately after
that this was an accidental discharge
that resulted in the tragic death
of mr right so the officer yelled taser
and was distressed so therefore
it was an accident and that's the
statement from the police chief now
what the police chief calls an accident
by the law
could be manslaughter and this has been
ruled a homicide remember
homicide can be murder but it can also
be manslaughter
brooklyn center minnesota police chief
tim gannon was asked
did you authorize the use of tear gas
and rubber bullets during the protests
he essentially says yes was it your
decision to release tear gas and
to um shoot fire bullets no
rubber bullets as a young protester sure
this is i'm the police chief in this
city police action is made by me
the decision is made by me does that
answer your question
then a reporter says you know if the
reason for the stop
was not having a license plate or having
an expired license plate
are you aware that there's currently a
multi-month delay
on license plates here and the police
chief just walks out of the press
conference
significant delay are you aware that
there's a significant delay
in getting tabs and things of this
nature from the dmv
so even people who have purchased tabs
are unable to get them because there's a
two to three month bath log
are you aware of that and is your staff
also aware of that
and have you made any type of
recommendations to your staff
to be mindful that we're in the middle
of a pandemic and don't pull
people over for tabs particularly
because there is a significant delay in
getting those tabs
from the the department of motor
vehicles are you aware of that
i am worried about the police i am aware
that is your staff aware of that yes
they are
that was the last question i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry
mr mayor matt asked you in that video a
female officer clearly made
a fatal mistake so this was very
abrupt bizarre he just walks off
and the brooklyn city manager appears to
be unable to explain why that happened
mr mayor when i asked that question
about
the firing of the police officer the
police chief left
yeah what is that an indication of is he
dealing with something perhaps more
important or
or is that some type of silent protest
because he left immediately
immediately i can't speculate mr mayor
you have a comment
i i i do not know why excuse me does
that bother you without knowing why that
he just walked out
i do not know why the chief left um you
know it
i can only speculate as to why uh
why he left it you know at the time that
he
what would your did be
i i don't i don't have any speculation i
mean it's possible that you know that
the chief uh
you know takes the position uh perhaps
similar to the city manager that
you know there needs to be uh you know
some
some kind of a process or um
you know i i don't know i can only
speculate
and i believe from the amount of coffee
i saw him chug
he needed to empty his bladder like how
how odd is all of this stuff
now then here is where it gets even
crazier
the police chief comes back did someone
tell him off screen
that looked terrible get back out there
so he's back and then he says the
officer needs due process
yes sir yeah ask you directly as i asked
the mayor
do you believe the officer who fired
this fatal shot and i understand there's
due process we get that
but ultimately she shot and killed a 20
or 20 year old man
the mayor has indicated she should be
terminated
what's your position on that my position
is that officer afforded due process
just like anybody else does
she has the right to be heard she has
the right to give her statement she has
right to tell what she felt what she
thought
not what not what i thought not what i
saw but what she thought and what she
and that may have an impact
she's on administration one time she
will she will not be
she will not be returning to duty until
this investigation runs course and
she for all intents and purposes i think
we can look at the video and
ascertain whether or not she'll be
returning
so everything the chief says there is
correct of course the officer
does get due process they should be on
administrative leave
and they are that's not the issue the
issue is more this guy's bizarre
attitude demeanor walking out
walking back in now i'm already getting
a ton of emails from people saying
this officer is going down this is clear
manslaughter they're going down for
manslaughter others saying
they're not getting anything here i i'm
going to give you my
both non-legal expert and cynical
opinion
about this case i believe that this
officer
will not be found guilty of any criminal
wrongdoing
i think that you will either see as far
as criminal goes
something settled resolved an agreement
before this ever gets to trial or if it
goes to trial
you will see an acquittal and you will
see a civil settlement for
big bucks with the family of dante
wright why do i say this
there's no question that if you mean to
tase someone
and you pull out a gun and you kill them
that's manslaughter colloquially
speaking
but the way that police
shootings are handled in the legal
system
with the taser warning they will they're
already pulling the games of well
you know this is someone who had a
running he had a i think it was a
warrant
for some minor drug related thing
they're going to pull out all the games
that they normally do
i'm not giving you my moral opinion i'm
giving you simply my prediction
i think that we will see
no guilty verdicts criminally for this
officer and likely a big financial
settlement with the family
it's going to be a long time could be
years before we ever get to that
resolution
uh but that's uh that's my sense at this
point in time tell me your thoughts
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights
from 10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video